(ressac)
♪ ♪ ♪
- Sur led d d de la White Bay,
caché au creux des montagnes,
le village de Wild Cove ne
compte que 46 habitants,
dont 4 enfants.
- Right there. Good morning!
- Good morning!
- C'est ici qu'a grandi
Clifford Small.
Son père lui a transmis
sa passion pour la pêche.
Jusqu'à 33 ans, il était
le capitaine du Lady Small II.
Le père de deux enfants
s'est ensuite réorienté dans
le secteur de la restauration
avant de faire le saut
en politique, à 51 ans.
♪ ♪ ♪
f f f f f Bays-Central-
Notre Dame est la deuxième plus
grande circonscription de
la province après Labrador.
Deux mois avant
le déclenchement de la campagne
électorale, le candidat allait
ààààà de porte en porte dans
l'espoir d'être élu.
Il a frappé à 10 000 portes
au cours de l'été dont celle
de Desmond Greene.
Clifford Small lui a demandé
d'être bénévole pour lui
sur l'île Fogo.
- This is the mayor
of Wild Cove!
- Si Clifford Small était
inconnu dans la sphère publique,
c'est tout le contraire pour
son opposant libéral.
Scott Sims a été présentateur du
Weather Network et présent sur
la scène fédérale depuis 2004.
Il a été battu par 264 voix.
À Wild Cove, sur les
26 électeurs qui se sont rendus
aux urnes le 20 septembre,
25 ont voté pour Clifford Small.
Albert Wells, le dernier
pêcheur du village, a voté pour
lui. Comme plusieurs pêcheurs,
ses attentes envers son nouveau
député sont immenses.
Et l'un de ses principaux
objectifs comme nouveau député :
inciter le gouvernement
à intensifier la chasse
aux phoques et commercialiser
ses produits à plus
grande échelle.
- We've been banned from world
markets, we've been banned
from the U.S.
- Selon lui, il faut convaincreé
d'interdire l'importation
des produits du phoque,
à revenir sur leurs positions.
Il croit également quele gouvert
trop influencé par les groupes
environnementaux.
- Seal gravy!
ststststststststement du phoque
braisé qui est servi chez
Keith Bath, un chasseur de
LaScie qui le reçoit pour
le souper de l'Action de grâces.
Pour lui, nul doute que
la prochaine élection amè
au pouvoir un premier ministre
conservateur. Une étape cruciale
s'il veut qu'ici comme ailleurs,
la viande de phoque devienne
plus
les assiettes.
Ici Maude Montembeault,
Radio-Canada, LaSci